17 ans qu'il est derrière son comptoir
andré a préparé des cafés et discuter
avec ses clients dans son petit bistrot
qui les met presque autant que johnny
hallyday seulement voilà l'ami dédé est
un peu fatigué je suis debout depuis
4h30 ce matin j'étais mes horaires
d'ouverture sont 6h30
mais les clients sont déjà derrière la
porte à 6h15 donc faut être courageux
comprenez courageux pour reprendre un
commerce comme le sien quand on réveille
la décidé de partir en retraite pensez
vraiment trouver quelqu'un pour lui
succéder
il y a bien vu un candidat mais la
sphère ne s'est pas faite résultat le
bar-tabac ferme dans moins de deux mois
un crève coeur pour ses clients tous les
petits commerces de merbau sont bien
utiles à la population
bien sûr donc ça vous attriste bien sûr
c'est dommage c'était un petit lieu de
rencontre qui était très sympathique et
sans être dommage on aura plus rien pour
venir boire le café et se rencontrer le
matin les bistrots ça monte toujours
dans un pays
et puis les gens qui viennent les b
s'ils font connaissent pas ils viennent
au bistrot plus vos connaissances avec
d'autres gens c'est comme ça que vous
marie a connu des gens jeunes arrivés
sur un repreneur d'ici le 1er mars
plus personne n'y croit bientôt d'aidé
ne fera plus de clés et mettra la sienne
sous la porte
amer est déjà nostalgique de beaux
moments de commerçants
le barbe lundi le dimanche matin et
milliers d'euros de cigarettes vendues
en une matinée
souvenirs souvenirs s'il y a un autre
bureau de tabac quelques rues plus loin
chez l'ami dédé était le dernier petit
café de cette commune de 2200 habitants